they told me i was too young to do this
they told me that
wnba players aren't entrepreneurs they
told me that nobody's done this before
and it can't be done
right yeah make them believe that's what
you're selling
that's the brand yeah
so ladies and gentlemen we got alex
jones in the house 2017
wnba champion uh she's part of a
company that i invested into called
queens gaming collective which supports
women in
gaming and she's also got a her own
company called so
raw hair and we're gonna talk about it
try to give her some advice
welcome aboard alexis thank you for
having me i'm excited
what do you got how can i help okay so i
just started
um my own company and
the reason why i started is because one
i buy here all the time like i always
put hair in my hair for the games and
i always dream the bike in the games too
eh you do it in the games
yeah i do but i wear long yeah i wear
long hair a lot of a lot of us wva wear
long hair
but i always go by like three four
hundred dollar hair and i'm like
man i can invest in my own like i i know
i like i know what type of hair like
and i can make it so much easier for me
and then i can also
you know show my other side what i like
to do with the haircut
so i just started this so raw hair
company and the reason why we call this
so raw here is because
the hair is really raw like it's really
raw hair
meaning that it looks super natural yeah
no meaning as in like
the hair like there's different type of
hair there's virgin hair
um like um like the mink hair but
we have like the the real raw hair which
is super thick on the thin
on the ends of it and it's like it
doesn't shed at all
like it's the real legit hair we got a
good vendor for it
and everything so that's why we call it
so right here and
i just started three weeks ago november
4th and
but i started online because of covet
and
right now i'm just trying to figure out
how to like
build my fan base because i don't really
have
like the hair hair company fan base and
also
bring that to the hair side so where i
can start getting sales and
understanding how to um do the marketing
like you know like how how much do i
need to promote what can i promote
or the content like do i need a lot of
because i don't have a lot of content
and pictures and stuff like that i just
have the same one so i don't know how
like i just don't know like i know how
to advertise i just don't know how to
just get started and get people to
wanting to buy
yeah so so what's the story behind it
besides
i'm spending a lot of money on hair so i
wanted to make my own version of it
well the story behind it is one
this i don't ever have my hair done like
so when i want some hair
i have to like i don't have time to go
you know like i play basketball all the
time
so i can't always you know wait two
weeks to get my hair done like i always
want to quick so
i was i just always been into hair and
my mom's my
my mom's sisters they all grew up in to
hair company so
it's just something that i feel like
would be a great investment investment
for me
and also i can give back to my own
community too as well like the black
community too so i was like
i'm gonna sell my own hair and i have
the time and opportunity to do it now so
i wanted to get into it and learn more
about it
what you need to have an angle you know
the so i went to the website
uh super quick and listen it's it's new
so don't stress but
just direction right so direction of the
website direction of your your own ig
direction of the of the the the sore
hair
ig what's missing is the like who is
this for and why it's so important
okay so you have a couple options it
could be um
the athletic side right of like hey this
is premium this stays in while i'm while
i'm shooting hoops
for any athletes who will struggle with
this like this is high-end
athletic hair right
option two is for the woman on the go
your hair is never done
you don't have time to go to the salon
you can't go to the salon with covet or
you know the restrictions but for the
women on the go
this is it it's going to look natural
it's high quality right
third option is you do the community
play
you know where you're from what your
family grew up in i want to get back to
my community
like either any of those three are good
potential paths
right now when you go and look at it
it's just here's the pricing
here's the hair there's no story to it
okay
so we need to have the story right it's
like why did you join queens
i joined the queens one because i was
when i was into gaming
yeah i was into gaming and i played it i
played 2k all the time
so i was like they came to me and i
started kind of getting
like competitive kind of like around
covert time and then i finally got like
an opportunity to like
be a part of them and told them like my
story of
who i was as like a wba player and
basically why i got into gaming so the
attraction of queens
the story with queens is what is missing
for your brand right like i got into
queens before queens
well you did too i mean you got into
queens before queens was ever a thing
right like yeah you go to the website
there is no website
it's coming soon but so how did they
hook you in it you know
they hooked me in it with the story of
wanting to
promote women in in gaming
and um you know i've seen i've seen what
it can do to a lot of women in game it's
not a super friendly environment
um you know you and professional sports
might be used to people yelling at you
and fans screaming
and but a lot of people aren't and when
they go into gaming a lot of women are
afraid to stream because
they're going to be yelled at by the
guys and then they don't have a you know
super thick skin yet um so i was i liked
the story
and i put money into the company when
there was nothing
just just an idea right you've got a
product you've actually got something
that people can order and they can buy
and they can put in and it works
you don't have the story now you do have
a story
but it's just not anywhere that's
visible
it just looks like another hair product
without explaining
the back story so you're on the website
right like you took some pictures of it
doesn't even say your name yeah
right so the fact that you're you know
wnba champion
that means something right
that you want a title that that that is
something so especially if you're
playing up the athletic
line it's like hey i'm an athlete i play
on the pro level we've won a world
champion this this thing stays in
you need to buy it okay so which of the
story angles feels the
the best for you you got pro pro
athletes
you've got busy mom or busy busy woman
on the go
who doesn't have time to do her hair um
and and the third one was like being
part of the community
yes so yes yes yes yes that makes more
sense
so to have a story in the way to have
the story how do you
do it does that mean by like a video or
or does that mean it's the whole thing
but like through those three things what
resonates the most
those three options what's the story
that connects the most
from for me would be sports
okay the women in sports so but i
also have but i also like women on the
go women who want to get their hair done
too so i like both too because i think
that's
kind of goes with the sports and women
on the go too
what what was that what was your um your
shoe
what was the message on the shoe make
him believe make him believe like i like
that
okay do you own like can you can you
ride with that or is that a
adidas thing no that's mine i made that
up i like it
yeah i like it i mean my my slogan is
believed so we're we're a line there
um i i like the ad if you look at nike
right you're wearing a nike
hoodie uh nike's brand
is is the athletes right it's like pro
sports you're gonna you're gonna be
kobe when you put on these shoes or this
hoodie or whatever but it's also the
aspirational
so anybody playing street ball or
or any kind of athletics or they want
they want the nikes the people just want
the nikes even if they're not into
sports because they
look up to these people right the whole
idea like you could have that
if you make make and believe the thing
for the whole company
then it's about women achieving
yes women achieving
women feeling accomplished women having
more self-confidence right i mean you're
not making them for me right
i'm not well i'm not i can't use your
product right
there's nothing a lot left up here um
but make and believe as the as the
slogan as the aspirational the athletes
are using it
and then that trickles down to say oh if
she's using it i want to use it too
i want to i want to be like her yeah
that's what that's what
you know nike and all the all the great
companies that's what they're so great
at with the branding it's the story
okay yes so i need to figure out to
create a story in order to
get people in into wanting to buy the
hair
and i can use that with like i can
probably use that with any content
pictures to post anything right
for the website for the product
description right not that
not only that it's raw like the nike
shoes have uh
there's features in each shoe right i
mean they'll show you the thickness and
they all do something but but
there's a feeling like if you were
wearing if you had that hoodie on and
didn't have the swoosh
it wouldn't feel the same no it wouldn't
it could be the exact same
same color same text but it doesn't have
the swoosh
it's just an ordinary hoodie decent
quality even nike doesn't necessarily
have the best quality
they make a lot of low stuff too right
they make the super high-end but they
also
make a lot of low-quality stuff but
people still buy it because they want to
feel like they're kobe when they put on
those sneakers or or hoodie or whatever
right
yeah so same thing for you is like when
i'm when when your customers like when
i'm putting in
the hair i want to feel like i'm going
to make people believe
yeah okay i feel like
i have i have my hair like
like i do i swear i do a whole bunch of
stuff in my hair like i have to wear it
my hair i didn't wear my hair for like
three months and i think that's like
probably too long for like most women
but
that's good hair and i know i i have a
lot of like i've been wearing a lot of
different women's hair and a lot of
those hair
having like it don't last for me or i
don't like the picture of the hair like
those has been my problems or the hair
is too thin
you know like so i have to go to like
these different different hair companies
i'm just like at this point
i go find my own vendor and find what i
like and give people back
what i you know and show them that yes
the problems that you're solving are
great like why your hair is a better
quality but
but you don't want to be in the feature
comparison game
and you definitely don't want to be in
the low price game like
you don't want to be in the hey buy for
me because i'm cheaper okay
that's not the path to win i need to
feel better
about myself when i wear your hair
like when i wear your hair and i'm going
to go do whatever i do and it could be
in sports but maybe maybe it's a
you know single mom going to a job
interview
her first job interview and and she
needs to make them believe
she needs to make you know that person a
hiring manager believe in her
that she can do it and by putting on the
hair
it's the that's the boost
yeah that's putting on the hair that's
what it is
that that's what you're selling that's
the brand yeah
okay and then inside the product
i never put that two and two together
though that's the thing
like that's what we're here for we're
we're doing it
like i put the you know like you the
belief was into like
my basketball my soul my you know
the dedication of what i'm going through
and making poli people believe in that
but i never put it into like
so right here make them believe and then
now like you got all these different
things coming up in my head about
the different like i can still be me and
still promote my product in a lot of
different ways
okay so alexis make him believe is not a
basketball thing it's an alexis
life thing like your
friends by hanging around you you make
them believe in themselves
so everything you touch is make them
believe
yeah so so the hair is just an extension
of your friendship it's like i get a
motivational talk with you every time i
put on the hair because i feel a little
bit more
like you yes okay
so okay okay okay i see
so that just shifts so now when i look
at your website when i look at
each you know the packaging when i look
at the the actual hair when it comes
when i look at the box it comes in when
i look at your content
it's all through the lens of making
belief
okay and now you you know you wear it
when you're doing your games
um i would try to like product seating
means you give your product to people
who have influence so i try to see the
product with
with your friends who are in the league
yes who people could look up to as well
some of the recognizable names
maybe some of the past stars who who
have a bigger brand
like i don't know who the who's the
biggest wnba star of all time
they see the difference between them a
lot of them don't wear
that type of hair okay so
that would be like a makeover
literally well it's got to feel natural
right and maybe they're
maybe they're down for it but maybe
they're not right but that's it like not
everybody's going to be up for
for the style okay lexi brown wears it
and lexi supports me so lexi brown was
like gonna be
one of my marketing person for it and
then kennedy i mean i can be um
kalani kalani brown that plays for
bailey we went to school together she
wears hair too
so she's not a superstar in the league
but she has
a good fan base and she wears she wears
weave and stuff like wigs
and stuff like that yeah so you start
you start with your wnba pals and then
and then you branch out like who else is
doing
uh look at women athletes across america
in different sports
and you reach out like you could tell
you just look at their picture you can
tell how they're wearing their hair
you can you can make an edge i probably
wouldn't know if they've got a weave or
not but
you do
and so you reach out and say hey we've
got we've got it's performance hair
right okay if you wear your hair like
this this is the best version like this
is the highest quality product you can
have
uh and you'd couple that with make and
believe
and it's crazy because i i have somebody
else to help me her name is jasmine
and i brought her in because she does
she she's an
um expedition so she does makeup she
does
um eyelashes she does everything so she
don't think that she doesn't do is like
hair but she has the facial product so
that she has the facial product too what
i wanted to mix in too so but that was
just like a slow way of
like mixing it in kind of but
we also have like that i wanted to mix
that in too so that's why i'm glad like
the making believe is like just
harping on all type of my ideas right
now my heels it could be any alexa's
it's anything it's shoes it's hoodies
it's it's
street wear it's hair it's makeup it's
like whatever you want to do
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry get it
so once i start can doing all this i
think that's when i can start getting
those that share
and and getting people to believe in
what i really want to do
and that's going to help my that's
that's going to help my content make
more sense of what i want to post and
why am i posting it
and you need to make women just make
them believe when you're putting on your
hair
you gotta you gotta you gotta show how
it makes you believe in yourself more
yeah and i don't need and i think yeah
i think even some some cool video even
if it's not a real live shot but if
you're
in the dressing room getting ready for a
game and part of your game ritual
is you put on the hair like i'm ready to
step out on the court
but i don't do it without my hair
exactly
right yeah so the same thing in life
like i'm ready to
single mom trying to step on the court
and go get her job interview that's her
stepping out on the court
yeah but she's not doing it without the
hair because that's what makes her
believe
exactly because i can't go out here
looking like this
right this is not gonna make me believe
in anything
right so but that's a great piece of
video content right
like whether it's actually pregame or
you could just
borrow the locker room you know and
pretend you're going out on the game
when you're getting ready
that that's what uh that's what nike and
all the other brands do so well
is most people who buy nikes are not
going to be in the nba or wnba or
professional sports right
it's mostly the wannabes but they feel
like they're kobe when they
put on those shoes right they feel like
a champion
right where if you strip the logo off
and just give them the exact same shoe
they're like
what is that it's just a shoe so that's
what we need for your hair is that
we're gonna feel more confident and
ready to step out onto the cord of life
with the hair like that's our uniform
that's our cape
that's our superhero outfit right there
yeah and i know i can probably put like
i have a lot of content
already where i can like probably put
like sniffers and videos of just like
me and my hair in different ways of like
me
you know me playing basketball with my
hair down like or
just different okay i i have ideas but
yeah so like you just take just do it
and then make it believe
yes make and believe this is your
version of it so nike
if you look at their products they will
have a detailed description of what
each shoe does and how it was
scientifically engineered for the
perfect
whatever which you should still have for
your products but it's
the above is the brand and your name
needs to be on it
you know it's okay for your name to be
on you
what do you mean of course why not well
i think but yeah
okay you're you're you're a wnba
player that's awesome
what do you mean by my name like what do
you mean by my name needs to be on it
like
because we already have so right here
make them believe alexis jones
whenever your picture is there i i don't
you don't necessarily need to be on the
like
in the brand every time but whenever
your picture is there it's set
put alexis jones got you you go to your
website you're there you're on the front
cover
you know all all dolled up awesome but
i don't know who you are right i mean if
it said your name they may not even
recognize you because you might look
different than
you do in the game right so
alexa just like you do on youtube about
alexis jones and then
2017 wnba champ got you
that you wear this thing that means
something yes
and then any of your friends who can do
it who also have any kind of
uh who also in the league or x league or
one something
you put them in okay that makes sense
so la but what about so when you do all
this
and then the promoting it
like on the social media base like i
think that
that's another thing like when you
promote it i think sometimes it makes
you feel like you don't get enough
like looks and people to click
on your page and stuff you need to
show how it's actually a part of your
routine
and helps you believe that's it as
opposed to just something you're repping
yeah right you can tell the difference
when it when somebody comes on like
yeah go buy cornflakes it's great
but like no you actually you love this
thing you need this thing
this helps make you believe and so it's
it's talking about in a way that feels
right like it like a game time
you're you're getting ready for your
game when you're putting this in
or whenever you would normally put it in
like you go and you make a video saying
hey i haven't i haven't gone to the
salon in three months
and i gotta go do whatever i gotta go do
an instagram live or a forbes release or
something
i i'm putting in my hair i can believe
let's go
and at the end is always making believe
like you tell a story
just do it it's always at the end right
it's like some story
some some obstacle that's in the way and
then
they overcome it and then just do it
that's the same thing it's like some
story about something that you have to
come up and face that is real that's in
your life like i don't know what
challenges you're facing on a day to day
but that's all
potential content if you want to bring
people a little bit into your life
and then at the end is always make them
believe
and that that tagline is way bigger than
just
a hair company yeah for sure for sure
gotcha the hair company is step one
but that's easy something you can
partner with people like you can partner
with your
your your beauty person to do a line you
can partner with a fashion company to do
some fresh hoodies you know you can
you can partner with people on different
projects that all still that you feel
comfortable with right like the makeup
is going to be something you would
actually wear not just
makeup because it's a deal right yeah
the hoodie has got to be fresh in the
way that you would actually wear
yeah but those can all be partnerships
with people that you make
yeah yeah are you streaming
are you streaming 2k yes i streamed 2k
and i also got on to
i got on to fortnite and but i i'm into
what is it um apx i don't know how to
say it okay it's another shooting game
that i really like now too
but i am on 2k but everybody like
nobody's going to park no more because
everybody's in the next generation so
i'm like kind of left out right now
so i've been getting on my shooting game
it's it's the kind of thing like
any anytime you do a big win like you
you you win the fortnight match or you
you
you dream a long range three or whatever
on stream it's like make them believe
it's like becomes a thing that you say
you win the fortnight make them believe
right like
make them believe yeah yeah yeah yeah
right yeah and then whatever like
whatever comes to mind like they told me
i couldn't do
this they told me they told me i
couldn't play
they said whatever the story is like
they said
women can't play games they said x y z
make them believe right
yeah people will get they'll get
obsessed with that right i want to go
buy your hair now even though i'm never
going to use it
yes i got to come out and do a video
right
just to have it next to me so it's like
making to make me believe right
um that's that's the branding that's the
thing because i know there's a story
there's a deep story here because you
don't just get
you don't get to where you are and what
you've done without hardship and without
story
for sure so just you gotta you gotta let
people in on it
and i think people will resonate and if
you can translate that beyond just
again like beyond just uh athletics or
professional sports to
no i'm walking out onto the court of
life
and i need to make the people around me
believe
i don't think i'm like the first wba
player to actually
if you probably could look it up to ever
come out with their own
hair hairline company like
that's something like and i'm young too
doing it trying to figure out how to
figure out and do it
like that's a that's a great promo piece
for the brand right it's like
they told me i was too young to do this
they told me that
wnba players aren't entrepreneurs they
told me that nobody's done this before
and it can't be done
right yes make them believe yes right
and the crazy part about it i have the
perfect picture for it
now that i have it in my head i had the
perfect picture to like set it out
and do everything and like i never
thought about putting that piece into it
so that that's going to definitely help
out a lot to have a story
because then it's going to be perfect
because then while i have another
business partner we both can tell our
different stories at the end of the day
too how she's grown to come up and what
she wants to do and i can do
my story to build to get her fan base
and get my fan base and we can just keep
going up
that makes more sense yeah i mean as
long as her story relates to make him
believe
no it does at this point anything is
making believe at this point like yeah
we're believing we ever we both have a
story to tell
like yeah so yeah
we just got to end it with this we just
and i think that's what we was trying to
get out of
of trying to figure out like did we need
to go
put you know put get get more product
put it in my hair
try to make a cute video and you know
and
do different things like this other than
just being
just real and you know what i'm saying
getting to the nitty-gritty and being
like yo
this is why we're doing this this is my
story in the background
and like
like how i feel like i'm the first wba
player to do it um
there um i'm a black woman doing it in
the wba too
if you want to be honest if we want to
be technical and
i'm i do it i swear and wear my hair all
day and i can
lay it again and there's nothing wrong
with it and i can brush it out you know
just make yeah i got yeah
all the things like they told me this
they told me this they told me this they
told me this
they told me i was a girl couldn't do it
they told me
a black woman couldn't do it they told
me i didn't have the education they told
me i didn't have the money
they told me whatever like whatever's
real to you i'm just kind of making
stuff up but like
whatever is actually deep and real in
your story
and that you're still you're doing it
like you're gonna go make him believe
make him believe
got it that's the piece right there i
think that's my biggest piece right here
to like
to keep pushing it every single day to
have something to write about every
single day
and to know what to post and and
sometimes we can just go in there and be
ourselves you know
so you know what i'm super excited for
you know in 10 years you're now the
person
investing into the next generation of
wnba entrepreneurs and showing them how
to do it
that's how i feel too and like yeah and
it's crazy because now like
me coming out we're doing it it's like i
don't i don't worry about like you know
trying to be
the first youngest player to do and this
is now i know now it's like oh
she's doing something let's see what she
does with it you know
and i know i'm going to do something
with i have no problem with it but i
think like now like i sit down and i
have to really tell my story and be like
i am the first woman to do this in the
wba
i am the youngest to do this in the wba
i am determined to show
that women can be pretty and beautiful
and sell here to to other
you know businesses and believe in us
too that
we don't have to be or a regular girl on
the streets that don't sweat
all the time to to want to you know to
be like that's what you have to buy like
you can be athletic city you know
different type of shape big everything
and
you can still buy hair from an athlete
there's nothing like i know
about hair too just as well as anyone
else you know
so yeah i think that's why i kind of
like my story to kind of like tell
you you just leave with the you leave
with the negative
more right like they told me i was an
athlete so i couldn't run a business
yep they told me i was whatever they
told me i sweat too much and i couldn't
use a hair product or whatever right
like they told me this or they basically
tell you when you're a woman
if you're not a superstar you're not
going to get a lot of endorsements so
but now you have to make it even better
it's like they told me i couldn't get
endorsement so
so i made my own company you know like
that's making believe right
that's right right there that's it
that's definitely right that's fake and
belief
that's definitely the slogan of the year
because that's definitely like facts
like that's basically what they tell you
they told me because it like in my head
it doesn't make sense why black women
wouldn't want to come to a wba player
and you know make us their ambassadors
that doesn't make sense to me you know
we wear your hair all the time we sweat
in it we do a whole bunch of stuff in
your hair
and it we can i feel like the athlete
shows the real product because we gen we
sweat in the hair
like you know like we sweat we use it we
know
exactly what the hair is gonna do feel
like if it's gonna
last long if it doesn't last long you
know like
yes they did tell us that we couldn't be
ambassadors for our presence for our own
hair
yes i like that slogan yeah
and now you're on a mission right that's
the difference now mine isn't something
real
yes and i get a great product i mean the
product was always great
but now now i'm buying into a movement
yes
i think you'll crush it you just just
always see it through that just put
those glasses on
always i got it now i got the glasses on
now though
this is a good start i think this is a
great start i think this is the next
step for like
i think it's going to help us build our
content more without wanting
without saying without trying to be like
others you know i'm saying like
like be more like us and use what we
have
and not try to go do more photo shoots
and you know like just be
me just be us at the end of the day so
yeah
i think this is a great content for us
but i think we have a lot of content for
this
of us being personable yeah this is
i didn't think this is dope
even lean into that like they told me i
had to be perfect to sell hair
they told me i had to have a fancy photo
shoot to have hair
yeah to sell this product
and then you film from your bathroom or
something like you just film in just
normal areas
where all the other companies are like
fancy stiletto heels
like yeah in the north pole or something
right
yeah they do all that stuff and it's
cool like i like all that stuff like
i love to dress up and doll up like
that's my thing to do when
you know like if i could do it every day
you know what i'm saying i would love to
have that as a job but that's just not
reality right now
but like that's i think that was our
vision
of like oh well we need more products to
show
them all the stuff we got behind doors
so people can buy you know and
in my head i'm just thinking like well
one is covered two
i'm not i want nobody to rob me i don't
want nobody knowing all the products i
got up in my house you know like that
was my thing like
yeah i got the product but i don't want
everybody to know you know like that's
cool like i can i
like at this point i can get you the
product that's not the problem
like you don't have a store to be you
know to just be doing all
to be but it's the same thing like they
told me i needed a store
yeah like that's
that's just making believe you don't
need a store we're going to make it
happen
make it happen we're going to make them
look they told me i needed a store
they told me i needed a degree
making believe we got you got like you
got lots of it
any hardship any adversity you know like
you just
throw it up there man i got now like we
can make our own
like i think now we i can do like a a
photo
of just seeing like a lot of different
things a lot of different slogans
and i can just post those slogans
probably like without pictures on it
with different pictures of just like
they told me i could do this with the
hair and i hear
make them believe you know like just
give all those different slogans of like
of telling my story in a in a different
in a different way besides putting it in
a comment but
but do it as in the way of like it's a
meme do you kind of get what i'm saying
yeah
yeah yeah play with it for sure but it's
got to show it's got to show like
the doubters the haters the yes the
people who told you you couldn't make it
yes that's what i'm thinking like make
it to where like there's a photo because
but i want people to really read it as
in like now like it could be like a
quote
too in a way but they really can read it
read it so
it's just like we have all these memes
like they told me i was a wba player and
i didn't want to buy here for me here
goes this beautiful picture of why you
can buy hair for me
then here goes another picture they told
me that i couldn't be pretty and dolled
up
and sell my own hair boom you know like
just all these different memes that we
just keep posting every single day but
it's of our businesses and just keep
posting them every day
to get people to understand like why are
we doing this why are we doing this and
then you know just
yeah backing with different things the
key is every time when you're you're
about to post that content
it's got to feel real yes every time you
post the content
right like your heart is the
ultimate test does it feel real to you
to alexis
right not just because you can get ideas
from other people's channels or pages
like oh that's a good meme post
but it's got to actually feel real yeah
for you
yeah because you're the brand your heart
is the brand
so it's your story and if it's your
partner or or
also if you have an athlete that you're
now giving it to and they're going to
help promote it
what is her make and believe story
that you connect with right so me was
like they told me i was too overweight
to be an athlete they told me i was too
short to play ball
they told me i was whatever right make
them believe and that might
that may not be your story but it's
their story and you're like yeah
i i feel you like i feel you in your
story
i feel you and your story even though
it's not mine right yeah
yeah when you feel that connection to
somebody else like you
you pull those pieces out and that's
what you share on your content and
that's going to be good because then
it's going to let other people share
their story too
yeah you're giving people permission to
believe in their dreams
yes and to believe in whatever they want
to believe in
i like that that that's what's going to
build the fan base that's going to build
everything the context everything
and that's what's going to bring the
people that i want from my fan base too
to understand why i'm doing this and i'm
not just doing it because
whatever y'all think of whatever cause
that y'all want to do it so
i think yes i'm happy i needed this
all right well i'm excited i'm looking
forward to the progress
thank you i really appreciate this a lot
this is
very mean meaningful and i think it's
definitely going to help me because i
think the content was like
our business start to like trying to
understand how
to to get the sales kind of and to keep
everyday post alive without being like
yo we need to go do
spin get all these people that want to
do pictures
and you know like now i have people who
want to be pictures and stuff so now i'm
just like
yeah i can go get dolled up all the time
you know that's cool but
i that that shouldn't have to be you
know like our
our motto to keep making money like to
get people to sell
you know like there has to be another
way that we have the pictures that we
already have to get people to understand
like
we have the product you know what i'm
saying yeah you show in real life you're
showing real life
it's real life and and sometimes real
life is getting dulled up you're not
anti getting dulled up yeah you're not
seeing like getting dulled up as the
is the enemy or the devil or something
you just show in real life and that's a
that's a piece of real life but it's not
the whole thing
yeah yeah that's it yes that's exactly
what it is
okay thank you all right alexis cheering
you on we'll talk soon
thank you okay appreciate you good luck
ciao
if you want to see my sit down with
shark tanks kevin o'leary check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there 50 of the population hates you
because of your ideology you had to be a
little bit crazy to be an entrepreneur